very good morning to you and first of
all First Minister just on what's going
on behind me as you cast your eyes south
of the border with no effective
government and opposition in in disarray
how would you describe the situation
utter chaos shambolic and frankly
disgraceful you know a time when the
whole United Kingdom needs leadership
probably more than it's needed
leadership in any part of the post-war
period
you've got the Conservative Party and
the Labour Party completely abdicating
responsibility and they're letting down
people across England across the entire
UK and I look on in utter horror it is
shameful and somebody needs to get that
act together my responsibility of course
is to provide leadership in Scotland and
I'm determined to do that both to try to
navigate a path through this situation
created by the referendum a situation
not of my choosing but as we do that
also to make sure that Scotland
continues to be governed in a stable and
effective way so that's what I'm
entirely focused on as far as Minister
of Scotland and I think frankly people
in England deserve better from the
political leadership and they're getting
to be okay well share with us your
thinking and particularly for the vast
majority of voters in Scotland devoted
to remain within the European Union
flesh out for us the process by which
you think the EU may be able to offer
Scotland a way to stay within the EU
without actually having to leave hold an
independence referendum and then rejoin
well I don't know that that will be
possible what I am determined to do is
explore all possible options to give
effect to hope people in Scotland voted
and to protect Scotland's interests to
avoid us being taken out of the European
Union against their will with all of the
deeply damaging and painful consequences
that that will entail so that's my
guiding principle to protect Scotland's
interests I'm not starting from the
premise of seeing it's got to be
independent
I'm starting from the premise of what do
we need to do to protect Scotland's and
trades but if it does appear to be
obvious that the only way we can protect
Scotland's and chests is by looking
again at independence and that's an
option that Scotland has to have and of
course a second independence referendum
in these circumstances would not just be
a rerun of the 2014 one because the
context is completely changed the UK
that we voted to remain within in 2014
doesn't exist anymore and of course what
many people saw is the stability of the
UK versus the unknown of independence in
2014 is completely different what we
know for sure is that the UK faces real
uncertainty and deeply damaging economic
consequences of a brexit so independence
may be the best option of securing
stability for Scotland inand that's an
option that we must have the right to
consider what did you say may it may be
an option but just be explicit for us
and you don't know the the answer to it
but is the question you are putting to
the European Union is there a way that
Scotland can maintain its membership and
maybe still stay part of the United
Kingdom we have said the big sporting
that option amongst all options we are
come in completely unchartered territory
right now and you know here people
seeing or well you know when article 50s
triggered this will be able to happen
that won't be able to happen the truth
is none of us know this is unprecedented
that's never been done before and what
will happen from now on will purely be a
matter of negotiation my job is to
negotiate on behalf of Scotland to try
to get the best outcome for Scotland so
nothing is off the table in that but my
guiding principle is to try to give
effect to the Democratic will of the
Scottish people as expressed on Thursday
and to act in the best interests of
Scotland and as we go forward I'll be
honest with Scotland about the
complexities we face this is not going
to be straightforward but I'm absolutely
determined to try to get us through this
in a way that best protects our
interests and to do it in a way that
tries to unify people in Scotland
because this situation is not of our
making we didn't
choose it but we have to do with the
reality we're knowing and tell me about
your conversations with the other parts
of the United Kingdom that voted to to
remain within the European Union with
the Mayor of London and the deputy first
minister of Northern Ireland well I've
had discussions with a variety different
people across the UK in the week of the
result in first is that he can I spoke
to on fraidy morning you know he's in a
similar position to me of course out in
chess I'm not identical and we may
choose different paths in the times
ahead but London voted to stay in the
European Union as did Scotland and you
know he's as anxious as I am about the
prospect of London and me of Scotland
been taken out of the single market with
all of the consequences that that will
entail so I think we're keen to work
together to try to explore common
interests where we can and Northern
Ireland of course is you know facing up
to some very difficult to consequences
as a result of this vote different
position and the sense that the Deputy
First Minister's position is different
from the First Minister's position but I
want to make common cause with as many
people as possible as we all try to
navigate our way through a very
difficult set of circumstances and you
know city can labor is in turmoil today
and if I was in labor in England which
I'm no obviously but I would see Sadiq
Khan is one of the few bright spots that
Libra has to say I think he's a class
act and it's been a real star since he
was elected as the maid of London and I
hope very much that I can work with them
is we tried to respectively protect the
interests of the people we serve I'm
interested in those discussions you had
Martin McGuinness say in Northern
Ireland I mean one of his and shin veins
and other people's fears are that there
may have to be a physical border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic if one
country is who remains within the
European Union and one isn't and well
how does that then apply to Scotland
that idea if Scott and remained within
the European Union as you want and that
England left would you not need a
physical border well I do what's the
important between Scotland and England
and and you know in any circumstances
but you know
here is a very good point that almost
regardless of what happens in the
Scottish context some of these very real
issues are going to have to be faced up
to and resolved in the irish context now
you know nobody can see that you know
those in the leaf campaign weren't
warned of all of these consequences and
you know i think people in ireland
should rightly be very concerned about
the prospect of a border between the
north and the south and i hope that is a
way that can be found to avoid some of
these consequences but you know these
are consequences not of our making not
of Northern Ireland's making they voted
to stay in as well but there are
consequences that we now all have to
deal with and what's vital at this
moment this is the most difficult woman
I think for the UK with the the most
serious consequences in the post-war
period and what everybody needs right
now is leadership clear leadership not
leaders who pretend that the way forward
is easy but leaders are determined to
lead us forward with purpose no Scotland
has that that is my promise to the
people of Scotland it's about time
politicians and Westminster got the
attack together that have provided that
for the rest of the UK - yeah and
leaders who of course have answers and
do you have the answers it was a must
asked question during the last
independence referendum it what what
suggestions then let me put it that way
because I was going to ask you I was
going to ask you about the currency
because of course the last time around
we we got the answer that you would stay
within the Sterling zone things would be
very different this time round are you
considering joining the Euro or setting
up an independent Scottish pound joining
you I will come back to the point of
cuttings in a second so I'm not trying
to dodge it but can I make another point
first and this is about you know you say
leaders got I've got to have answers of
course if we get to the point of a
second independence referendum we will
have to have worked through all of these
issues and have the answers there but no
leader right now in trying to provide
leadership should pretend that all of
these answers exist right now because we
have been placed into this unprecedented
situation and what leaders have a duty
to do right now with the people they
serve is to navigate the way through
these and find the best answers out of a
definite
circumstances now you know on currency
yes what are the most difficult issues
of the 2014 referendum and of course
it's an issue we have to work our way
through this time to but you know we're
in a very different situation if we are
facing a second referendum this is not
about Scotland wanting to leave anywhere
this is a bit Scotland wanting to stay
and to protect the situation that we've
got just now so if anything the model
case we've got for keeping our own pound
and for keeping the the circumstances we
have right now is even stronger than it
was in 2014 now what I'm going to do in
the weeks and months that lie ahead is
be very honest with the people of
Scotland as we try to find a pass
through this I'll not pretend the
situations that are difficult underneath
are easy or the answers that make take a
bit of time to find it can be conjured
up instantaneously I'm determined to
leave Scotland forward in a way that
finds the best way through this in a way
that unifies people in Scotland as much
as possible and if that means me going
to the people of Scotland over the next
couple of years and seeing in my honest
opinion the best way for us to protect
our future is to become an independent
country then I will do that and I will
seek to take a majority of people
Scotland with me what about the
immediate future First Minister we have
the issue of article 50 the the process
article 50 of the Lisbon Treaty the
process by which the United Kingdom
would formally announced its intention
to leave the European Union as that
happens and your views on when it should
be triggered but if and when it is
triggered
how closely must Scotland in your view
be represented at those talks and
negotiations Scotland has to be
represented every stage of this process
and our interests have to be represented
in every eventuality and I'm determined
that that will happen but I think a very
important point I have to make is that
I'm not going into this accepting as
inevitable that Scotland is leaving the
European Union because Scotland voted to
stay in the European Union so my
objective is not to find the best way of
Scotland exiting the European Union is
to find a way for Scotland to stay in
the European Union there's lots of
things I'd like not avail
the European Union in future I'm just
saying that listen listening listening
to that yeah there is a bit of a delay
but are you saying you might already
have cut a deal then with the European
Union so damn it damn it
I would Scott it the UK voted on
Thursday I think you know the best world
in the world would if I had been able to
cut a deal by Sunday then you know that
would I think be rather surprising I'm
not sitting here saying I've cut any
deals with anybody what I've seen as
First Minister of Scotland I'm gonna do
everything I can to give effect to how
the people of Scotland voted on Thursday
and just to remind people more than 60%
of people voted to stay in the European
Union people in every single local
authority area without exception voted
to stay if I as First Minister simply
shrug my shoulders and said that I
accept it as inevitable that regardless
of that we were going to be removed from
the European Union I wouldn't be fit to
be First Minister I'm going to do
everything I can to protect the
interests of the country I'm elected to
lead but just to clarify that article 50
question that poacher it was rather got
I suppose cross purposes during the
delay on the line what I was asking was
given that the Prime Minister's
formulation that he believes that
doesn't need to be triggered perhaps
until October I'm not talking about a
weekend you would have several months
then of Scottish discussions with the
European Union of course yeah absolutely
I will be seeking to have discussions
with European institutions with other
member states as quickly as I possibly
can I'm not really set around waiting
for the turmoil in Westminster to give
way to some kind of order the leadership
my job now is to delete and try to find
a way forward for Scotland I just think
people across the rest of the UK had
been badly laid down right now you know
the UK needs leadership right now and
somebody's going to have to step up to
the plate and deliver it good to talk to
you first minister thank you very much
indeed the First Minister of Scotland
Nicola Sturgeon that